on Twitter we're Kenyans and Nigerians
are having a serious go at each other
over Lupita Nyong'o latest role the
Kenyan actress will play the lead
character in a 10 episode screen
adaption of the novel americana
Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie's 2013
bestseller follows the love story of two
nigerian teenagers separated in their
journeys to pursue an education in the
West the girl goes to America and the
boy goes to the UK and they both have to
deal with being black abroad we'll find
out why some Nigerians think Lupita
won't live up to the character but first
let's listen to Chimamanda Ngozi Adichie
talking to DW about how the book
Americana changed her life
I think it freed me hmm I think because
Americana is a book that I its book I
wanted to write and I didn't want to
follow convention and in some ways I
hadn't actually seen anything like it
which is to say the story of immigrants
from Africa but who are not escaping war
or poverty but simply want more who have
dreams you know in the way that I think
human beings have had for centuries that
we sometimes wake up and we think we
want to see what's there right because
what's here isn't enough and I wanted to
tell that story because it's a story I
know that's the kind of immigration that
I'm familiar with and it's not to say
that the other kinds of African stories
are not important but simply to say that
we can have a wider range of African
stories that are told and so I wrote
Americana not it wouldn't show that
anybody would want to read it really
because I don't think it fit any of the
kind of recognizable forms or formats
for an immigrants so back to the
controversy on Twitter my colleagues
Edith Kimani in Nairobi and fro chakra
in Lagos are going to unpack that for us
it's good to see you ladies flourish
I'll start with you why are Nigerians
having a hard time accepting an
oscar-winning actress to play the lead
character a female you in the Americana
series
well this is clearly because if Emmylou
in the series is a Nigerian woman first
of all the book was written by a
Nigerian so we're trying to you know own
that proudly and they believe that there
are so many talented actresses in
Hollywood that could have been picked to
create this role but this is really
about many people having this ideology
that Africa is seen as a country and so
as long as it's an African role it has
to be repeated which people are trying
to fight against okay so either coming
to you you've read the book you know if
Emmylou what do you think anyone playing
this role needs to bring out and and why
do you think Lupita is right for the job
well I guess because of the obvious
reason she is the best person for the
job she's an oscar-winning actress after
all and her story like that of a family
and many other Africans reads like he
does in the book an African who's
removed from her continent and has to
battle with her identity when she finds
herself in an alien place is this what
you Peter needs to be thinking about if
you ask flora she might tell you that
it's the ebo accent she needs to be
really worried about okay so talking
about that ebo accent eat it and it is
that's right many Nigerians are worried
about whether she'll be able to pull it
off so I guess you're gonna have to
stand in for your girl right now and
convince Nigerians like flourish that
Lupita will nail the ebo accent give us
your best shot edit just for the record
I am NOT Nigerian I'm not an actress I
don't know how to do accents but
flourish we beg you oh let's our girl do
the parts she's gonna nail it and she's
African I personally don't think it's a
big deal but then again I'm not Nigerian
and it might be a different case if it
was a Kenyan rule being cast to a
Nigerian
okay eat it so if I were judging that I
would give you a straight up you are not
getting a role in any Nollywood film but
I'm gonna need that to flourish to do
flourish you be the judge of that how
did either do with that hopeless in my
opinion ebo accent
I'm not going to I'm going to try not to
be too harsh because II deep is not but
if I were to cast it is for the world
she's definitely not getting it and I
hope Lupita does a better job than than
that Lupita is a great actress and I
wish out all the best right well you
know this could have all been solved if
people cost a Zimbabwean all right so
that's flourished Agora in Lagos and
Edith Kimani in Nairobi we're all
looking forward to that Americana series
film it will show be interested to see
how Lupita does after all girls thank
you